talent is the great equalizer of all the
things that people are scared of don't
worry America everything will be fine
talent still matters
[Music]
we were born in the Soviet Union I was
how much do you think that shaped who
you are now an enormous amount I think
being born in the communist country as a
purebred capitalist and then having the
great fortune to be able to come to
America and then to be really not
wealthy and not have stuff as a kid to
be emotional that my parents bought me
two star wars figures when I was six and
knowing that that was an enormous deal
to know that when I wanted stuff my mom
was very quick to tell me go buy it
yourself and go earn it it absolutely
absolutely absolutely shaped me and the
other thing you know especially in the
political climate we all live in now I
don't think people understand how
amazing America is it makes me
enormously optimistic very positive and
those are very important traits if
you're going to be insane and actually
go after entrepreneurship how did you do
this whole thing you built it from the
ground up I've been producing content
online for 10 years early YouTube when I
started the wine show for life my prior
career
[Music]
and about two or three years ago it
wasn't doing the wine show anymore I was
once in a blue moon putting out some
content but it was building up I'm like
there's an opportunity for me to talk
there's new thoughts in my mind and we
started a show called the askgaryvee
show
[Music]
ask gary be
and then vlogging started taking off on
YouTube more and so kind of the marriage
of YouTube first person vlogging and
reality TV became the concept behind
dailyvee which we started earlier this
year and it's become a very substantial
part of the brand building of myself and
my agency
I think it's really smart to create a
North Star worse engineer seven years
ago after making a lot of money on
investments decided to build an agency
full-service media buying creative
strategy video production all of it not
just one like the rest of the agency
world and I was going to build it for
myself and so I was going to take a step
back eat crap because you have to have
clients and that stinks especially when
you've already made your money how do
you do that cuz you're very outspoken
person I do it like you crap because
they're the boss my dad has a Russian
saying whoever pays for the music gets
the picket when you were in those first
years you took advantage of YouTube very
early on as you said was there ever a
fear of well if I'm not creating the
video content maybe I'm focusing on the
wrong thing I've always had one
substantial advantage against the market
which is I just worked 13 and 14 and 15
hours a day if you're competing against
people that are working seven and eight
and really five and six when you count
in lunch and a couple of youtube videos
and like you know phone call or two I
was never worried about that I always
had enough time to be what I am which is
the CEO of 100 million dollar revenue
agency and you know especially with the
infrastructure around me now because I
have a five person team which is really
a modern-day production company what's
been the hardest lesson for you to learn
your life but I can't do everything what
are things you would love to be doing
that you're not doing nothing I'm in
full control of my life if there's
something I want to do then I can go do
it we make our beds so I sleep in it
what do you think about all the
Evangelist today who talked about you
know you need more sleep you need to
work less all of it is very personal I
don't need society telling me how to do
work life balance I don't need society
telling me how to raise my children uh
that being said I'm a huge advocate of
sleep I'm all in for six seven I mean I
always try to get six or seven hours
it's like that's plenty am I just some
more worried about what you're doing
while you're awake right now like not
wasting your time and trip for someone
of your main things do on if your
complaint now by the way this is only if
you complain if you don't complain you
can do anything you want this is one of
people saying I wish I had or you got
lucky or this is unfair for those people
if you're on for softball teams
and watch entire seasons of stuff on
netflix you you can't complain do you
watch Netflix I don't I consume the
reactions of my community to my content
and that's why I / index with my
community because I've allocated my
leisure time or my escapism revived and
providing value and I hope through
example and content I'm able to inspire
that but i think i think practicality is
grossly under rated and for all my
sizzle I'm obsessed with the steak
because in the world of advice giving
there is tons of sizzle and not a lot of
steak I don't do that by the wall street
by the way I don't think I'm in the
advice giving business and I understand
why everybody would think that I think
I'm in the documenting what I'm up to
business I'll quick little walk to the
garden haven't done this yet so I'm
excited about that ok rock clear that
they're doing them what is that like
what are you pointing it look what do
you think it is then that attract people
to you I think they understand genuinely
that I have no interest in getting
anything out of them the only thing I
want from them is their attention I'm in
return i'm willing to give them
everything I've got
I think when I look at my contemporaries
AKA other people that are in the advice
giving business there's always a punch
line at the end sign up for my course
come to my event travel to my
destination thing I don't want anything
from them I just uh I just want the
thing that my mom gave so much to me
that I still need it which is I want
their attention what do you think of the
influencers and the desire among so many
people to become influencers now I'll
separate them what do I think about the
actual influencers that they're the one
of the two or three best deals and
advertising what do I think of
everybody's aspiration to be one makes a
whole lot of sense sounds like a lot of
fun to make three hundred thousand
dollars a year taking selfies with
products on Instagram but but
ninety-nine percent of the people
watching are talented enough to actually
create an audience what do you think
because you know everything about who
you are whatever public everybody should
try really because everybody who wants
to should try this is why this is why I
think that this is why I question your
thought on that because every site widow
this gets this is fun but everything you
stand for yes authenticity and being
true to what you are who you are there
are so many influencers now who not all
of them but a lot of them in order to
make that three hundred thousand dollars
a year you have to endorse tons of
products some of which you probably
don't actually stand for yeah and so
what will happen over time is that
audience will start to walk away from
that person if they're not creating
enough value in return I think it's a
value exchange I also think that we're
educating our clients of just cuz she
has four million followers if when she
says buy this if they don't believe her
you're gonna waste money and I think as
the maturity of the market understands
that authentic executions gonna really
matter that's what you built your
business yeah listen I have never done a
sponsorship deal on my content in 10
years and I got often in 2006 to put
bottled water on the table why didn't
you do it then because i knew i was
gonna make money in a different way and
i didn't want to lose the exchange once
you ask for something you've lost
leverage what was the lowest point for
you so far along the way 4th through
12th grade
why because I wasn't built to go through
that horse crap of a education machine
that America is for kids that are
purebred entrepreneurs what were some of
the experiences you had teachers telling
me that I would never succeed in life
while I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards and making more
money than they were making for all my
bravado and ego I got really lucky my
parents gave me the right DNA I have a
lot of humility I didn't need to prove
it to those teachers I didn't need to
razz them I didn't need to stick it to
my friends parents who didn't want their
kids hanging out with me because I'd be
a bad school influence and I wasn't
going to be a winner I grew up in an era
in the 80s and 90s when education was
the only way to win like you were going
to be successful if you went to Harvard
and then one there was no conversation
around entrepreneurship when I was a kid
entrepreneur meant you were a loser what
is the worst advice you've received
along the way almost everything
anybody's ever told me advice is bad
unless it's contextual and you really
dig deep I give very little advice to my
employees until I start to really get to
know them and so most people like to
give advice without context the best
advice only comes from the people
closest to you and the ones that I've
actually have your best interest in mind
not theirs that means almost nobody
because that means everybody sending
outside and a lot of times the people on
the inside I mean mommy and daddy are
giving you advice in their best interest
not yours so how do you differentiate I
just don't listen to anybody and I come
back to hurt you in any way I do sure
but I'll take where I'm at and I mean in
life not like in business like like it's
so funny how your flaws can end up
becoming your strengths my enormous need
for attention has made me give so much
more to my audience than I ask in return
because I know that will give me more
attention my sense of self has made me
obsess over how many people going to
show up to my funeral which then makes
me want to be nice to everybody along
the way because what do you want them to
say about you at your funeral what do
you want me just you know being that
ever lived the greatest human being that
ever lived that didn't take my advice
yeah I mean I mean I don't think
anybody's gonna be there by the time my
funeral nobody's going to be there
try to give me advice you know because
there's only there's nobody left like
it's unbelievable how visceral I am to
advise like nobody even attempts at any
more trip for people out there who are
feeling stuck they've been trying over
and over again to get what they want
that's not working out what do they do
something severe like get a divorce or
stop talking to your dad or or quit your
job I mean it I mean it well let me tell
you why stop talking to your dad sounds
like terrible advice until you start
realizing the thing that I've come
across over the last year or two which
is most people don't do things because
they're scared to fail in front of
somebody and then you start on whining
and you realize my dad they're scared to
fail in front of somebody who's within
their inner circle who they love the
most who's holding them down poison is
bad it's bad when is the last time you
were afraid I'm afraid every day what
are you afraid of the health and
well-being of my family and I mean for
real I'm actually more scared than
almost anybody I know I've never been
scared in this you're neurotic I'm just
genuinely concerned about the health of
being in my family why are you afraid of
them dying I love them very very much
I'm being very serious with you like
work never usually I ask people for
their best piece of advice to people but
since you're not in the advice giving
business for people who see what you've
built and they wish to emulate it in
some way what do they do they have to
punt almost everything besides their
family and work 24 7 365 hard as hell